.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Ich habe dieses Jahr
viel von den Gräben gehört,
die es zwischen den Städten
und dem Land geben soll.
Existiert vielleicht ein Graben
zwischen Land- und Stadtbevölkerung?
Stadt-Land-Graben -
das Thema der linksgrünen Städter,
die angeblich
das Land bevormunden wollen.
Sie denken,
sie seien etwas Besseres.
Sie denken, sie könnten sich
den Fuss am Land abstreifen.
Der Graben spielt in der Tat
bei bestimmten Themen stark mit.
Offensichtlich gibt es in der Schweiz
urbane und ländliche Lebenswelten,
wo die Menschen
unterschiedlich ticken.
Ich will
in solche Lebenswelten eintauchen
und mich dem Phänomen
Stadt-Land-Graben annähern.
Die Stadt Zürich -
ein Anziehungspunkt,
auch für viele Menschen,
die auf dem Land aufgewachsen sind -
so wie Geograf und Politik-
wissenschaftler Michael Hermann,
ein Spezialist, wenn es
um Stadt-versus-Land-Fragen geht.
Er stammt ursprünglich
aus Huttwil im Emmental.
Ich lebe jetzt 30 Jahre
in dieser Stadt.
Dadurch
bin ich schon sehr städtisch.
Aber was man mitbringt,
verliert man nie.
Und was ist das?
- Also, es ist ja doch ...
Meine formativen Jahre
verbrachte ich auf dem Land.
Ich bin so aufgewachsen.
Es hiess immer: "Die Studierten
kann man eh nicht brauchen."
Sozusagen: Auf dem Land
wird noch richtig gearbeitet.
"Die Städter
sind ein bisschen komisch."
Dort war damals die Drogenszene.
Diese Bilder
habe ich immer noch im Kopf.
Ich war froh,
dass ich vom Land wegkonnte.
Ich passte nur so halb dorthin.
Er habe in der Stadt
über die Jahre festgestellt,
dass es Gleichgesinnte
oftmals an den gleichen Ort ziehe.
Das führt dazu, dass sich alle,
die gleich denken und aussehen
und gleich viel verdienen,
dann an demselben Ort landen.
So gibt es dann
wie eine Sortierung der Bevölkerung.
Das ist ein bisschen absurd.
Man denkt, dass alles so nahe
und so digital sei.
Trotzdem
wird der Graben immer grösser.
Auf der Suche nach Spannungsfeldern
zwischen Stadt und Land
landete ich im Oberwalliser Binntal.
Hier geht es um die Frage,
was mit alten Landwirtschaftsgebäuden
ausserhalb der Bauzone
geschehen soll.
Diese Frage
ist im Raumplanungsgesetz geregelt.
Rechtsanwalt und CVP-Politiker
Aron Pfammatter sagt,
dass es bei der Raumplanung
Differenzen gebe zwischen den -
wie er sagt - urban geprägten
Bundesbehörden und den Bergkantonen.
Das hat auch der Basler
Christoph Birkenmeier erlebt.
Er wollte hier im Binntal mehrere
Hunderttausend Franken investieren -
in den Umbau
einer alten Stallscheune.
Welche?
- Die unterste da links.
Ja, die unterste von den dreien,
die man da sieht.
Man kann direkt hinfahren.
- Ah ja, genau. Da geht es rüber.
Wie gesagt, die Strasse existiert.
Eine Expertenkommission
des Kantons Wallis
hat diese Stallscheune
ausserhalb der Bauzone
als schützenswert erachtet.
Der Umbau wurde bewilligt -
unter strengen Auflagen.
Vor Ort
ist auch der Einheimische Theo Imhof.
Er hätte den Stall verkaufen wollen.
Gehörte das Ihrem Vorfahren?
Ja, ich habe vor 50 Jahren
da drin gehirtet.
Natürlich. Wir brauchten die noch.
Meine Eltern waren Bauern
und betrieben Landwirtschaft.
Wir hatten hier noch Vieh.
Was wollten Sie damit machen?
Zu Wohnzwecken nutzen.
- Zu Wohnzwecken?- Ja, klar.
Aussen bleibt sie unverändert.
Von aussen würde man nichts sehen.
Es gibt keine neuen Fenster, nichts.
Man darf den Boden nicht begradigen.
Ich will keinen Sitzplatz
oder Chalet machen.
Ich will keine Fahnenstange
und keinen Grillplatz.
Das ist wichtig,
weil das in den Köpfen drin ist.
Das will ich ja auch nicht.
Natürlich hätte ich das mit
der örtlichen Schreinerei gemacht.
Binn kämpft darum,
dass der Dorfladen erhalten bleibt.
Wenn kein Laden ...
Natürlich würde ich hier einkaufen.
Hm? Also ... Ja, klar.
Doch die Beamten des Bundesamtes
für Raumentwicklung in Bern
legten Rekurs ein.
Die Stallscheune
sei nicht schützenswert.
Der Ärger über die Berner Beamten
ist hier gross.
Da steckt der Geist
der Zentralisierung drin.
Sie erheben für einzelne Baugesuche
bis in die Gemeinden Einsprache,
sogar in der Bauzone.
- War das früher nicht so?
Nein, man übte
viel mehr Zurückhaltung.
In unserer Verfassung
steht immerhin,
dass die Raumplanung
Sache der Kantone ist.
Das wird
immer weniger berücksichtigt.
Man hat ein Misstrauen
gegenüber der Kantone.
Man denkt, man müsse ihnen
auf die Finger klopfen.
Dieser Geist steckt da drin.
Juristisch vertreten sie
eine absolut extreme Meinung.
In dem Verfahren hier
sagten sie quasi,
dass sich kein Stall
als Ferienhaus eigne.
D.h., es gibt keine Umnutzung,
obwohl das in unserem Gesetz steht.
Jemand in einer Stadt
hat keinen Bezug zu so einem Objekt
und weiss nicht, was für schöne
Dinge man daraus machen könnte,
ohne das
auf gut Deutsch zu verhunzen.
V.a. die Argumentation,
dass es eine Bauruine sei.
Man zeigt keine Wertschätzung mehr.
Es ist ihnen egal,
wenn das alles kaputtgeht.
Die Wertschätzung fehlt.
Beim Bundesamt für Raumentwicklung
sagte man,
es sei für den Charakter
der Landschaft gefährlich,
wenn nicht mehr benötigte Ställe
zu Ferienhäusern umgewandelt werden.
Man müsse dosiert
und umsichtig vorgehen.
Auch ihnen gehe es darum,
Sorge zur Landschaft zu tragen.
Die Zweitwohnungsinitiative
zeigte ja auch,
dass das Schweizer Volk will, dass
in den Bergen weniger gebaut wird.
Das muss man doch akzeptieren.
Wir akzeptieren das auch.
Das geht ja nicht anders.
Die Zustimmungs-
und Ablehnungskarte war extrem:
Alle betroffenen Kantone
lehnten das ab,
die anderen stimmten zu.
Es gibt da
sehr viel Interpretationsspielraum.
Aber es ist
die nicht betroffene Mehrheit,
die für die betroffene Minderheit
entschied.
Die Gemeinde Binn, die von
Bevölkerungsschwund betroffen ist,
hat den Umbau unterstützt.
Aber am Schluss gab das Bundesgericht
in einer umstrittenen
und knappen Entscheidung
den Raumplanern in Bern recht.
Aus der Stallscheune
darf keine Wohnung werden.
Darum reagiert man so gereizt, wenn
die Städter - wie man sie nennt -
uns sagen wollen,
was schutzwürdig ist und was nicht.
Ich finde, das ist klar
eine kantonale Kompetenz.
Ob es wirklich nur die Städter sind,
muss hier offenbleiben.
Klarer ist der Stadt-Land-Graben
beim Thema Wolf.
Wir sind unterwegs
in der Val Lumnezia,
dem Tal des Lichtes,
im Kanton Graubünden.
* Ruhige Musik *
Dann müssen sie bei der Mauer rauf
und dann sofort links.- Ja.
Während der diesjährigen Weidesaison
hatten Wölfe im Kanton Graubünden
über 100 Schafe und Ziegen gerissen.
Eine Herausforderung
für Bauern wie Erwin Derungs.
Guten Tag. Hallo. Christof. So.
- Guten Tag. Erwin.
Wie geht es? Beim Mittagessen?
- Gut. Nein, schon fertig.
Schon fertig.
Wir würden gerne zu den Schafen.
Die sind auf dem Maiensäss.
- Ah.
Der Rest ist auf der Alp.
- Ja.
Ein neues Jagdgesetz hätte den
Kantonen mehr Kompetenzen gegeben,
u.a.
für präventive Abschüsse des Wolfs.
Doch das Schweizer Volk
sagte letzten Herbst Nein.
Du hast schon den Zaun aufgestellt.
Seit wir Wölfe haben,
ist der Aufwand viel grösser.
Wie lange hat es in der Val Lumnezia
schon Wölfe?
Das ist jetzt das dritte Jahr,
wo es viele hat.
Vorher gab es nicht so viele?
- Nur ab und zu einzelne.
Den Zaun musste ich nur wegen
der Wölfe unter Strom setzen.- Ah.
Früher musste man das nicht.
Rund 120 Schafe hat er -
ein paar Dutzend hier im Maiensäss.
Hey, "dschüta".
Was sagst du?
- Das ist Romanisch.
Hey.
Hast du den Wolf schon mal gesehen?
- Ich selber noch nie.
Noch nie?- Aber schon viel
von anderen gehört, die ihn sahen.
Er war schon mehrmals im Dorf.
- Da unten?
Er hat dort schon
eine Mutterkuhherde angegriffen.
Neben dem Haus.
Da oben
ist immer ein Rudel unterwegs.- Ja.
Wie hast du
beim Jagdgesetz abgestimmt?
Natürlich Ja. Es war bitter nötig,
dass es angenommen wird.
Man sieht das Problem dieses Jahr:
Es wird immer schlimmer,
wenn man die Problemwölfe
nicht abschiessen kann.
Nicht alle, aber die,
die über den Zaun springen.
Ja.
Aber du machst es anscheinend gut.
Du hattest
noch keine gerissenen Tiere.
Ein, zwei Wölfe
sprangen schon über die Zäune.
Die bringst du nie mehr weg,
wenn sie mal anfangen.
Beim Rudel dort drüben springt
der Vater in alle Zäune rein.
Das gibt er den Jungen weiter.
Das war ja
eine Stadt-Land-Problematik.- Ja.
Die Medien haben das entschieden:
Schweizer Fernsehen, "Blick" usw.
Sie schrieben gegen die Bauern
und für den Wolf.
Ah ja?
- Die Medien haben das in der Hand.
Es wird ja fleissig
über gerissene Schafe berichtet.
Aber man zeigt nie ein Bild,
wie es wirklich aussieht.
Gerissene Schafe
werden nicht gezeigt?- Ja.
Lieber ein paar Welpen,
damit man es süss findet
und für den Wolf ist.
Aber wie es auf der Alp aussieht,
das sieht man fast nie.
Was für eine Lösung siehst du denn?
Wir müssten die Problemwölfe
abschiessen können.
Früher und schneller schiessen?
- Ja.
Es gibt viele Wölfe, von denen
man nichts merkt oder hört.
Die stören uns ja nicht.
Beim Jagdgesetz haben sie hier
in der Gemeinde Lumnezia verloren.
Aber oftmals sind die Landregionen
auf der Gewinnerseite.
So sagte die Gemeinde
im vergangenen Juni klar Nein
zu den beiden Agrarinitiativen
und v.a. zum CO2-Gesetz -
ein Herzensprojekt vieler Städter.
Wie war es denn
mit dem CO2-Gesetz hier?
Wir waren dagegen.
Wir brauchen ein Auto.
Da wart ihr also dagegen.
Damit wird bei uns alles teurer.
Die Randregionen
sind angewiesen auf ...
... das Fahrzeug.
Da waren die Städter nicht zufrieden.
- Nein.
Spürt ihr den Klimawandel hier?
Ja, es wächst mehr, wenn es regnet.
- Es wächst mehr?
Die Tiere
haben mehr Futter als früher.- Ja.
Man merkt es also.
Wenn es etwas regnet, hat man
auf dem Maiensäss mehr Ernte.
Manchmal hatte man ja kaum was.
- Okay.
Das Kulturhaus der Gemeinde Lumnezia.
Buna saira.
- Buna saira. Bainvegni.
Und?
- Grazia fitg per l'invitaziun.
* Sie antwortet auf Rätoromanisch. *
Die Ausstellung
"Der Wolf in der Kultur"
zeigt das Tier als Faszination,
aber auch als Bedrohung.
Diese Ambivalenz
sollte hier spürbar werden.
Anlässlich einer Diskussionsrunde
zwischen Einheimischen und Gästen
durfte auch ich
ein paar Fragen stellen.
Inwieweit
hat die ganze Schweiz das Recht ...
... mitzuentscheiden wie wir ...
... im Wallis oder ihr im Bündnerland
mit dem Wolf umgehen?
Es ist klar, dass die Bundesvorgaben
natürlich für gewisse ...
... Kantone störend sind.
Aber das ist
bei jeder Abstimmung so.
Gewisse Regionen werden überstimmt
und müssen sich im demokratischen
Prozess damit arrangieren.
Im Umgang mit dem Wolf
gibt es kein Richtig oder Falsch.
Es gibt unglaublich unterschiedliche
Perspektiven und Wirklichkeiten.
Eigentlich hat jeder recht.
Es werden heute punktuell
Wanderwege aufgegeben,
weil niemand mehr dort hinten ist.
Das hat nichts mit dem Wolf zu tun.
Der Wolf wird zum Sündenbock
des Strukturwandels gemacht.
Eine kontroverse
aber kultivierte Wolfsdiskussion.
Später sind wir Gast bei Aus-
stellungsleiterin Anne-Louise Joël.
Sie sagt, Kunst könne in diesem
Spannungsfeld zwischen Stadt und Land
als Brückenbauer dienen.
Wie ich die Debatte verstanden habe,
ging es in der Abstimmung letzten
Herbst nicht nur um den Wolf.
Sonst wäre das anders ausgegangen.
Man hat das ja untersucht.
Die Leute merkten schon,
dass man das lockern sollte,
damit man es regulieren kann.
Das ist auch das,
was ich von den Touristen höre,
die in die Ausstellung kommen.
Ich suche ja den Austausch.
Gewissen ist gar nicht bewusst,
dass wir hier Wölfe haben.
Wenn man darüber spricht,
sehen sie schon ein,
dass wir die Freiheit brauchen,
um uns so einzurichten,
dass wir auch hier leben können.
Es kann nicht sein,
dass nur der Wolf hier leben kann.
So emotional
dieses Thema auch sein mag:
Das Jagdgesetz ist eine Ausnahme.
Die Einwohner auf dem Land
haben in den letzten drei Jahren
bei Abstimmungen viel öfter gewonnen
als die grossen Städte.
Die Städte haben
zu mehreren Initiativen Ja gesagt,
z.B. für bezahlbare Wohnungen.
Die Landkantone haben diese und
andere Initiativen bachab geschickt.
Dennoch halte sich der Aufschrei
in den Städten in Grenzen.
Vielfach ist es so,
dass das Land sich bei Abstimmungen
häufiger durchsetzt
als die grosse Stadt.
Aber sonst nimmt man die Stadt
als extrem dominant wahr.
Gesellschaftliche Trends
gehen oft von der Stadt aus.
Das sagen auch die Leute vom Land.
Das vermittelt dieses Gefühl von:
"Sie dominieren uns."
"Sie wollen uns vorschreiben,
wie wir sein sollen."
"Sie schauen auf uns runter."
Selbst, wenn es in der Politik
häufiger umgekehrt ist.
Auf dem Land
besteht die Wahrnehmung,
man werde nicht ernst genommen.
Diese Gefühlslage
lässt sich politisch gut abholen.
Im Juni feiert die SVP-Spitze
die Versenkung des Rahmenabkommens
mit der EU im Kanton Schwyz.
Reden
tun auch die Städter aus Zürich.
"Die Freiheit
wohnt wieder auf dem Land"
nennt Nationalrat Roger Köppel
seine Rede.
Ihr solltet häufiger
nach Bern kommen.
Ihr solltet vor Frau Sommarugas
und Herr Bersets Büro trycheln.
* Jubel und Applaus *
In den geschlossenen Abteilungen
im Bundeshaus ...
... kamen alle
schon mit Ohropax auf die Welt.
* Lachen *
Sie hören teilweise
nicht mehr so gut,
was hier auf dem Land erzählt wird.
Sie denken,
sie seien etwas Besseres.
Sie denken, sie könnten sich
den Fuss am Land abstreifen.
Ihr müsst denen mal sagen,
wo Bartli den Most holt ...
* Jubel und Applaus *
... und wo die Schweiz,
noch die Schweiz ist.
Also, die Trychler ... So!
* Jubel und Applaus *
Im Wallis spricht der Fraktionschef
der Mitte-Partei, Matthias Bregy,
am 1. August vom Stadt-Land-Graben.
Er macht sich stark
für den Finanzausgleich
zwischen den Kantonen.
Und gegen den Wolf.
Nach dem Rösti-,
droht nun ein Stadt-Land-Graben.
Und damit, meine Damen und Herren,
die nächste Zerreissprobe
für unser Land.
Eine Zerreissprobe, die wir als
kleines, wenn auch reiches Land,
eigentlich gar nicht ertragen.
Wie zerbrechlich
ein einzelnes Stöcklein wird,
wenn sich das Band der Solidarität
langsam löst,
erlebt das Goms
gerade am eigenen Leib
mit den vielen gerissenen Schafen.
Was der Wolf im Goms und
in anderen Regionen des Oberwallis
aktuell anrichtet,
ist eine Katastrophe.
Das Jagdgesetz,
geschätzte Damen und Herren,
hätte hier Abhilfe geschaffen.
Aber das schwindende Vertrauen und
Verständnis zwischen Stadt und Land
hat dies zum Scheitern gebracht.
Die Konsequenzen sind leider blutig.
Die Bauern im Goms leiden.
Die Bauern im Oberwallis leiden.
Hier müssen wir helfen.
Am gleichen Tag
macht SVP-Präsident Marco Chiesa
seine Kampfansage
gegen die linksgrünen Städte.
Das ist ein massiver Angriff
auf die Städte.
Man muss das mal umdrehen:
Würden die Städte sagen,
man könne das Land nicht brauchen,
es koste nur, es solle weg,
das seien Schmarotzer -
das ist unvorstellbar.
Das zeigt ja auch ...
Wieso funktioniert das so einseitig?
Das hat sehr viel damit zu tun,
dass die Wahrnehmung folgende ist:
Die Städte dominieren sowieso.
Und den Dominierenden
kann man eher mal ans Bei treten.
Dabei gibt es auch für
die Grossstädter sensible Themen,
bei denen sie sich
mehr Verständnis erhoffen
von den Menschen in den
Agglomerationen und auf dem Land.
Insbesondere, wenn es
um Mobilität und Verkehr geht.
Ich lebe hier
und bin mit dem Velo unterwegs.
Alles ist in der Nähe.
Für mich ist ein Auto
nur eine Lärmbelästigung.
Würde ich aber in der Agglo leben
und reinkommen wollen,
oder wenn ich Handwerker wäre
und mich bewegen möchte,
kackt es mich an, dass überall
Hindernisse auf der Strasse sind
und ich nicht vorwärtskomme.
Die Stadtzürcher grüne Politikerin
Gabi Petri ist eine,
die zwischendurch
gerne Hindernisse aufstellt.
Die Geschäftsführerin des VCS Zürich
will weniger Autos
und somit weniger Parkplätze
in der Stadt -
zum Ärger von
ausserstädtischen Gewerbetreibenden
und manchen Pendlern, die freie Fahrt
in die Stadt wünschen.
Mit ihr bin ich in der Lebenswelt
Grossstadt angelangt.
Früher fuhr hier
Hamburg-Palermo durch.
Jetzt ist es eine Quartierstrasse.
Das ist sensationell.
Der Verkehr geht aussen durch.
So kann das wieder
eine städtische Strasse werden.
Was heisst das?
Ja ...
- Nur für die Städter?
Nein, nein.
Das steht
für ein erträgliches Tempo,
wenig Lärm
und eine einfache Überquerung.
Wir leben ja nicht nur
auf einer Strassenseite.
Wir überqueren sie auch
und gehen einkaufen.
Es ist wichtig, dass Strassen
keine Trennungswirkung haben.
Sie mögen die nicht, die in die Stadt
fahren wollen, oder?
Doch, die dürfen natürlich kommen.
Aber wir sind froh,
wenn sie mit der Bahn kommen.
Schauen Sie nach vorne:
Da hat es weisse Parkplätze.
Da können alle parken.
Aber wenn nachts um 3 Uhr alle aus
dem Ausgang nach Hause gehen ...
Es braucht nur einen pro Stunde,
der eine Tür zuknallt
und mit seinem Freund rumbrüllt
und fertig ist mit Nachtruhe.
Auf diesen 60 cm am Rand
wird man stark abgedrängt.
Wenn es heikel wird, muss man
auch seinen Platz einnehmen -
damit die Autofahrer
gar nicht daran denken,
an falschen Stellen zu überholen.
- Aha.
Ist das nicht egoistisch?
- Nein, das ist selbstbewusst.
Geht nach vorne.
- Ein Kopfschütteln.
Ah, schau.
Manchmal habe ich Mühe damit,
dass Leute, die in Stadt kommen
und das Besuchs- und Gastrecht
geniessen,
sich rücksichtslos verhalten und
unsere Verkehrskultur nicht kennen.
In Einbahnen sind z.B. Velos
in der Gegenrichtung zugelassen.
Manchmal sind Leute
aus anderen Kantonen hier,
das sieht man
an den Nummernschildern.
Die regen sich dann auf,
wenn ich ihnen entgegenkomme,
weil sie nicht wissen,
dass wir da fahren dürfen.
Wir kommen ja gut aneinander vorbei.
Die Autofahrer sollen sich anpassen.
- Wir wohnen ja hier.
Es ist nicht nur ein Durchfahrtsort,
es ist ein Wohnort.
Sie sind Hausbesitzerin,
wohnen in der Stadt
und haben eigentlich alles.
Das ist ein schönes Quartier.
- Ja.
Das soll für die Stadtzürcher sein?
Nein, die sollen alle kommen
und es mit uns geniessen.
Sie sollen dafür sorgen,
dass es so bleibt.
Da haben wir Rechtsvortritt.
Sie sollen darauf achten,
kein Störfaktor zu werden.
Ah, ab in den Kampf.
Auf dem Markt in Oerlikon
macht Petri Werbung für den
neuen Verkehrsrichtplan der Stadt.
Grüezi. Stimmen Sie auch
in der Stadt Zürich ab?
Weniger öffentliche Parkplätze,
mehr Fuss- und Veloverkehr
ist Teil davon.
- Schokolade essen dürfen Sie.
Das kommt nicht bei allen gut an.
Grüezi. Stimmen Sie auch
in der Stadt Zürich ab?
Wegen des Richtplans.
- Der idiotische Richtplan?
Dann gibt es keine Parkplätze mehr.
Hier hat es ja ein Parkhaus.
Aber ich kann doch nicht
mit fünf Einkaufstaschen in den ÖV.
Sie leben in den 70ern,
als man einen Wocheneinkauf machte.
Heute geht man mit dem Velo
und zu Fuss.
Im sog. Transit,
auf dem Heimweg von der Arbeit.
Wollen Sie den Leuten vorschreiben,
wann sie einkaufen sollen?
Das ist bequemer.
Es gibt eine Massnahme,
die das Problem löst.- Ja?
Ganz einfach: Verbieten Sie
neue Beizen und Geschäfte ...
Nein, das wollen wir nicht.
- ... und Theater.
Es geht nicht um Besucher.
Das wollen die Leute.
- Keine Geschäfte mehr.
Nein, nein.
Keine Arbeitsplätze.
Alle wohnen ausserhalb.
Nein, nein.
Gabi Petri
setzt sich nicht nur für Velos ein.
Auf ihrer Homepage
macht sie sich auch für den Wolf
und gegen die Jagd stark.
Ade, merci.
Erinnern Sie sich an den Wolf?
- Das ist ein guter Punkt.
Warum setzen Sie sich als Frau,
die im Zentrum von Zürich wohnt,
für den Wolf ein?
- Das ist ein urbanes Element.
Die Leute in den Städten haben
ein idyllischeres Verhältnis ...
Sie haben fast eine Sehnsucht
nach dem Land.
Die Idylle ermöglicht
einen weicheren Zugang zur Natur.
Leute, die auf dem Land leben,
haben eher
einen nutzerorientierten Zugang.
Das eine stört
und das andere kann man brauchen.
Dort geht -
weit ab von Parteilinien -
der Graben zwischen Stadt und Land
durch.
Auf der Suche
nach dem Stadt-Land-Graben
fuhr ich vom Bergtal bis nach Zürich.
Dabei habe ich
aber die Mitte vergessen,
sagt der Politikwissenschaftler.
Das ist typisch:
Man interessiert sich meistens ...
Man geht ins Wallis,
an die richtig urchigen Orte.
Und dann kommt man hierher.
So hat man einen riesigen Kontrast.
Aber die meisten Leute
leben weder hier noch dort.
Der Stadt-Land-Graben
ist an den Polen sehr weit ...
Die gehen immer weiter auseinander,
aber dazwischen ist nicht nichts.
Die meisten sind dazwischen.
Sie kitten das Ganze etwas zusammen,
damit es immer noch hält,
obwohl es so stark
auseinanderdriftet.
Es braucht die Mitte.
Die Mitte:
Das sind v.a. die Agglomerationen
und die Kleinstädte des Mittellands.
Hier werden Abstimmungen
meist entschieden.
Heute bin ich in Frauenfeld.
Ich möchte an einen Auftritt
des Schriftstellers Pedro Lenz.
Sein Programm
spielt vom Lebensgefühl Mittelland.
Pedro Lenz, der Mann aus Langenthal,
hat jährlich bis zu 200 Lesungen -
die meisten davon
in Kleinstädten und Dörfern.
Da spüre er mehr Brücken als Gräben.
Es ist interessant,
dass alle Kleinstädter ...
... die Grossstadt kennen, weil
sie immer wieder dorthin müssen:
ins Kino, ins Theater,
um zu essen, um etwas zu sehen ...
... die Rolling Stones zu hören,
was weiss ich.
Alle Kleinstädter
kennen die Grossstadt
und können sich gut darin bewegen.
Die Grossstädter
kennen aber die Kleinstadt nicht.
Zürcher besuchen keine Lesung,
kein Kino und keine Konzert hier.
Das sorgt dafür,
dass die kleineren Orte ...
... die Verschiedenheiten
viel stärker spüren und kennen.
Sie sind viel weniger
in ihrer Blase.
Man spricht oft davon
wegen des Internets,
aber es gibt die Blasen
auch in der realen Welt.
Wenn ich in Zürich,
Bern oder Basel aufwachse ...
... kann ich sagen, dass ich
die anderen gar nicht sehen will.
Ich gehe in einen Club,
in dem alle so sind wie ich.
Ich wohne in einem Quartier,
In Langenthal
ist das gar nicht möglich.
Es gibt nicht eine Beiz
für jede Subkultur.
Manchmal höre ich Leute, die
mit keinem SVPler sprechen wollen -
aus Prinzip.
Das habe ich
von Künstlerkollegen gehört.
Und ich finde:
"Dann warst du nie in Langenthal."
"Dort geht das gar nicht."
"Dann könntest du mit einem Drittel
gar nicht sprechen."
Das geht gar nicht.
Du kannst in einer Beiz nicht
zwei begrüssen und einen ignorieren.
Wir müssen mit allen
einen Umgang finden.
Das ist ein riesiges Vermächtnis,
das die Schweiz hat:
die Durchmischung der sozialen
und ideologischen Schichten.
Das geht so weit ...
... dass die Arroganz der Städter
in Bezug auf das Umland ...
Wie ich es gesagt habe.
Die Ur-Berner z.B.,
jene, die aus Bern stammen,
sind fest davon überzeugt, dass es
weltweit nichts Vergleichbares gibt.
Als ich sagte, ich gehe nach Olten,
meinten sie: "Aber Olten ..."
"Du bist in Bern zu Hause."
"Wirst du die Aare nicht vermissen?"
Und ich sagte:
"Die fliesst ja bei uns vorbei."
Das wussten sie gar nicht.
Sie dachten,
nach Bern gebe es die nicht mehr.
Das war das Erste: die Aare.
Das ist für mich kein Problem.
Es gibt Dinge, die ich vermisse,
aber die Aare nicht.
"Immer, immer weiterfahren,
immer weiter, immer weiter,
durch das ewige, ewige Mitteland,
Schweizerland,
Aggloland, Parkplatzland,
Schrebergartenland,
Einkaufszentrenland,
Siedlungsbreiland,
Eternitfassadenland,
Teigwarensalatland,
Raclette-Öfeli-Schüfeli-Land,
Aromat-Streudosen-Land,
Kasperlitheaterland,
Radio-SRF-1-Land,
Luftschutzkellerland,
Muttertierhaltungsland,
Ortsumfahrungsland,
Autobahnzubringerland ...
'Am Brüttiseller Kreuz 5 km Stau
wegen Verkehrsüberlastung' -
und schon fährt es einem,
es fährt einem von selber."
"Und ich sitze ganz still,
wenn die Landschaft vorbeifährt."
Auch wenn Pedro Lenz vom Mittelland
und von der kleinstädtischen Schweiz
schwärmt:
Die Formel "Gutes Land, böse Stadt"
stimme für ihn definitiv nicht.
Das ist das Doofe daran.
Man schaut, wer die Guten
und wer die Schlechten sind.
Das ist eine alte,
romantische Verklärung:
diese Idee, dass die auf dem Land
die echten, besseren Menschen seien,
und die aus der Stadt
die Schlawiner und Vögel.
Das ist das, was mir nicht passt.
Aber dass es Interessenskonflikte
und sonstige Sachen gibt ...
Dass z.B. jemand,
der mitten in Zürich lebt und
perfekte Verkehrsanbindungen hat,
eher autofeindlich ist,
ist mir klar.
Deswegen
ist er kein besserer Mensch,
aber auch kein schlechterer.
Warum fahren die Walliser mehr Auto
als Stadtzürcher?
Weil sie andere Distanzen
überwinden müssen,
nicht, weil sie zum Klima
weniger Sorge tragen wollen.
Sie haben
einfach andere Lebensumstände.
Man muss sorgfältig hinschauen
und eine Lösung für alle finden.
Darin hat die Schweiz Tradition.
Es gibt tatsächlich Spannungsfelder
in der Schweiz.
Mehr Austausch und Gespräche
würden helfen.
Dann könnte die Schweiz
am Stadt-Land-Graben eher wachsen,
statt daran zu zerbrechen.
SWISS TXT / Access Services
puretype gmbh - 2021